than PR for inv me to conference and
of for
the
collaboration and I enjoyed days
i
as the title of my presentation is
Abduction Models and
Creativity There is also subtitle I will
Deal with the subtitle In The End of the
presentation In which is the Concept of
ecni openness We will see is
e
scien Because I can
anticipate that I think in Current
artificial intelligence program for
instance Deep Learning There is not
situation of ecni Open
ok
Ok so First of all i want propose
Attention a Concept of inference That is
very General that  you can ad can ad As
PR
any American philosoph
philosoph char Anders St that all
thinking is in Sign can be Icons ind or
symbols moreover It Is Always All
inference is a form of Sign Activity
where the word Sign includes
feeling image
conception
AR
Concept
as and  Age
and science agrees implicitly
with says that for instance an emotion
is active Activity is an inference is a
way of reacting to a situation and so
also
imming
imes diagrams Ars were described and so
These Of course are inferences
in when they are able to lead from  One
point to another Point We inference
following this Concept and inan
form syntic form cogn
in
means for instance propositions that
Deal with
the divide between syntic a prior cogn
for instance mathematics
and
posterior
ofas peculiar crea
relev inuc
Process
so The Great American philosopher we are
in  United
States
apy
Given
and Do You Remember
deduction Start from True premises and
you are Sure that you AR to consequences
this is not the case of Abduction
because example of Abduction in syis
terms in first predicate Logic is all Men
are
Mortal socrates is Mortal conclusion
socrates  is a man This is called fallacy
of affirming the consequent Because of
course It is very Simple and
intuitive socrates can be a dog Ok
but you perform Abduction That
is
hpo
hpo classical example is making a
diagnostic
hypothesis and
another Better example is discovering
something
new the  example of Kepler
thats the
elliptic Orbit
theet So What is important Toe that
Abduction is an
inference deduction is an
inference induction is an inference
usually We consider induction as A Kind
of
generalization Abduction is so to say
more
extended If you are using an analogy It
is  more difficult to classify
extend
vi
induction
but It is A Kind of Abduction because Do
You Remember that Yesterday We David
Kaiser
that
Cosmic
Good foring the P Because in Archeology
is not cosmic you have the and He said He
said that They
use
reas
the
breakfast
Mod  other presentation
That the computational Mod
so Model Based Abduction means that you
can perform
abductions using mods diagr
Vis
Reach hypothesis using sential
Abduction that refers to the us for
instance Natural
language or a Technical language
weal Abduction for
instu us
areu
modd Of course they are non classical  Logic
so Model Based means that we are dealing
with
diagrams Elementary
diagram
W
di diagram permitted Nikolai Ivanovic
levski to Discover the non Euclidean
hyperbolic geometry so it is a diagram
that to come back to to the conference
of these
days
cosmologist
Einstein to this
diagram because they  are able to speak
of many kinds of Space And So on as we have
seen
Yesterday So This is an
example Because you know in the
Elementary geometry until The Beginning
of 19th Century It was necessary to use
diagrams and diagram is a Model an
external Model that  you have to depict
for instance in a blackboard
so here there are some examples of Model
B cogn simulative reasoning of Any Kind
analogy already qued Visual iconic
reasoning Spal thinking thought
experiment The Most Famous thought
experiment Of The History Western
thought is the thought experiment
Galileo
Galilei  surp
aristotelian Vision the of the
bely internal
iner external
as perception is Of course kind of
Activity a perception as kind of
Abduction in It is A Kind of Automatic
Abduction the cat perceives the word in
Another Way so there are It is it is A
Kind of  synthetic cognition Visual
imagery many people use Visual imagery
through Reach result but also in
deductive reasoning there are Model
Based aspect When you make a proof a
demonstration for instance Method of
semantic table
geet
are
externalization
that can be more or less good and it is
important Emotion
Emotion I think that you agree with me
also Because the cognitive Science There
is the Tradition of
the embodied
and enacted extended cogn That considers
the R of the Body exem important in
cognitive activi so When You are in
front of a situation in and you feel an
emotion the emotion is not propositional
It is A Kind of Reaction that any fear
for instance explains
the situation Ok Just Ok This is example
of Model Used by Watson and Cre when
they considered two
Snakes this was important for the
Discovery of the DNA and
RNA Just  Show this example This is Toy
Mod of the planetary System
for instance useful not necessarily for
Creative Do You Remember that I Put the
name Creativity Abduction is the correct
word to speak about Creativity not
necessar They are Used in Creativity but
they can be Used for inst  totic AIM
Abduction manipul
Abduction of thinking doing is
thinking You are in front situation
Where you are looking for
hypothesis historical ex
is was
not
Ars need and Thank you to the
manipulation artifacts he was able to
Reach the hypothesis so thinking through
doing is different from planning  a
manipulation That is more similar to the
experiment to planning and experiment
but It is
important Scientific Creativity i
Cre const is the Given David gooding
epistem
epistem to This kind of AR that People
and
Scientist Build for instance
skch necess external
ar
learing
S problem of
Creativity
Ok
di
Modern mathematics so the
abandon on the part of mathematics of
the intuitive Word this was not good for
philosophy because philosophy was the
only discipline that dealt with non
intuitive aspect but also mathematics
and soon also Science would have
reached Kingdom
fall Because I made  example theistic
example so Yesterday We had apy apy of
dyas Reason mix with freen Real
arguments and Which is characteristic of
as generalization
Andi are considered intuitively weak
inference
so do not Pay Attention to All this Word
Pay Attention to the fact that falls
Score
faller Sometimes They  are
good because for instance generalization
in children and also in
mice is able to save their lives
because they make a generalization Only
For instance with One ex One negative
example so in this
sous
reasoning a
and
usefulness in
Logic When you make a fallacy and you
arrive to  a Truth It is also called
Material validity Because you do not
have correct form of the reasoning
but you
arrive
as
Fruit simple stupid im Ok that I like
slid
color not academically correct
but I Old
Research You can Perm use color
SL
Ok This is a  book Springer handbook of
Model Based Science It is more than 1000
Pages there
are the illustration of Many kinds of
modeling As You can see Models are
classified as
makeb
[Music]
par
trad
epistem
abstract
Ideal and or
abstract so
epistem Said but they are
fictional because
abct
AG I
do
S Models are
fictional Models Of course are different
from the possible Final result in terms
of Knowledge but they are the only tool
that was juristic capable arrive the end
in this S they are extremely fruitful
and not
if from perspec to abstract to
important permit to the researcher
to Fruit in
resch
Let
subosic
in reality
of S Models for instance the Model of
Pendulum is Ideal and abstract but any
every kind of Mod is a concrete
materiality because It is a Dra a sheet
of Paper It is Something in a  blackboard
It
is computation representation situation
and
Material in this S Only in S are never
abstract manifest model is a Model That
is
computational Mod for
instance is
example approximation of neurons one
physical in vitro networks of culture
neurons and the other cons in a
computational counterpart if  the
computational
counterpart
ADC
S
manif that can
work necessary
Forever can be also eliminated You can
withdraw a Model and produce Another But
if It is
manifest it is because It is
adopted Mod To Say just
Mod
andst
of epistemic
actions
abstract ideality can be Sol Rel empiric
iny
[Music]
and
Years AG On
inference organized By so I Do not spend
a lot of Time to speak again Against
fictional in
epistemology this is
modic
Maxwell
Maxwell important conning
Mag Of course to Finish The problem
of
fictional If you see the Scientific
Enterprise
final  reached and you have the Model
that was used to arrive to that Of
course Models seems
fictional Sometimes without certainty
inconsistent but It is Because you do
not adopt a Dynamic View of Scientific
Enterprise
Ok
Creativity
in Days example of Models Ah ok There
was also the presentation
by What was the
name That
spoke
have Find ACS that are to lead to the
non-deductive reasoning is
Wi It is ay but It is good because It
is crea Because of
the with Creative Abduction that are not
the soced Selective Abduction the ones
for of diagnosis  and so Creativity is
important
Ok I told you that you have to see
Science This Is A Kind of
suggestion
Point that a sugg by poer and ep After
poer Ok
So What is equic
Warfare
can use
F other
as Scientific Enterprise for instance If
you have to funds  you can also you know
Invent not
sugg Invent experim but Galileo invented
a lot of experim
to
Against is
illustration Smart activities of Galileo
That is epistem epistemic Warfare but
when you are Inside Your Activity of
Research you cannot use fictions in The
Sense of
stupidi or extremely  false
invented experiment experiment
but you have to
arrive to hypothesis
Abd Charles
Sanders
Said usually you arrive
to acceptable ok
but for so in for instance in diagnosis
You have to adopt some criteria for
instance the more simple of the
hypothesis that you can Guess is the
Better  the hypothesis Has to be
consistent with your Knowledge but this
for example is not True in the case of
Creative Because you can create
hypothesis That is completely Against
the status of Knowledge of that period
It is
irrelevant it is completely unacceptable
and in many cases also unacceptable  then
can be accepted later on Because the
situation of the background Knowledge
changes the Ras rasor is one of the
criteria for choosing hypothesis the
simple One maybe is the best
May hypothesis about the murderer is the
simple One the wife of course the
husband Medical diagnosis is
similar doesn't have to be
Used in the case of Scientific Models Ok
that person is Paul feab the one that
analyzed all the roric activities of
Galileo Galilei to defend the new
physics to defend the Birth of Modern
Science Ok so epistemic
warf
for the Scientific  Truth even we all
know scientif TR
arew
typic
sci we
canf
on
Abduction i
also recently published
handbook cogn of
Pages
ex [
Music]
the case of Selective Abduction That is
the one that typical of
diagnosis
crea
ecni
sit this means that you have There was  a
presentation the
constraints Just few Hours AG So you do
not have to have for
instance example Einstein but in front of a
bad
ecni You are not to Discover anything so
Thanks to an ecni Model ecni means that
also refers to the exploitation of the
environment cognitive Science  Speaks of
distributed cogn Human beings Always
delegate cognitive aspect to the
external
material
and e Mod
means refer
top
diagn
reas optimization That is good This is a
practical This is not a philosophical
problem It is practical problem and in
Archeology you will be in Another
situation And  So on but F I am Almost at
the End of my presentation
iend that in the case of Science you
need
maximization of etive environmental
sitness and cogn for example in Alp Zero
That is a Deep Learning program You Are
Not You are not dealing with situation
also in  the case of Deep Learning tool
artificial intelligence that with big
data
Res of the data and this is a Human
performance to Avoid SP generalization
that Can
generate to
conclude if
are
need to Maxim cognition for instance to
make a good New Discovery we are We need
New  discoveries in
Science we have to take care of
etive openness so the Question is is
discoverability
geise currently various aspects of
decision making in commercialized
research already quoted In These two
days for instance in Biomedical areas
are geop Paradis in discoverability
Science so Scientific Creativity and
Human  Creative Abduction in General so
They are geising Human
Creativity why Because the excess of
rendering Secret
P
bus Of course is exactly the contrary of
the Tradition of Mod Science In which
always There was
action in the transparency so I guess but
not alone
in
Sit
The Human  Creativity can be
geopad I think that we do not have any
other slides The Hand Book of cognition
and the last book was with the title
discoverability The urgent need of an
ecology of Human Creativity I had the
Opportunity to read
ecology
laud
latino All kinds of
ecy
not
epy Social epistemology and ethics
because there
are
as together Than You [
Applause]
For conv some
usy and what are the characteristics of
Discovery any Discovery for that Matter
and so I think this is a Very
interesting frame that brings in
Creativity
originality Into the frame  of mods and S
Thank
You
question question
no my thinking
sleep night has been done by Abduction
not by sitting in front of and writing
some equations outside mathematics bi
but I think a good Opportunity to Bring
Another View on How we Get
inferences
Accept
willim
Gene
People
extremity
something to in Add to that is done
computational and that
the can come to other Way
let Than You I
can use for instance equations
Fun the Concept of
Faction are compelled to make the
physics the aristotelian physics that is
only qualitative in the case of Newton
You have to have at your disposal the
differential calculus
and You have to the differential
calculus and this was made by li and
Newton So This was the fruit of
Abduction in
mathematics there is a famous book by
lacat proof demonstration and refutation
that is about this Construction  and so
Of course You can Take Advantage
todu Medic
reasoning
of artificial intelligence in Scientific
Discovery as A Kind of Help of
external tool
a
Thanks I really enjoyed
Talk I could Help buttice that you Avo
The Words inspiration and Intuition you
avoided the words
inspiration and
Intuition  and I was thinking
Why
ok char sers and me say in Human
beings there There is the possibility of
the soed extin
Abduction That is When you produce
instantly and suddenly a hypothetical
result and It Is true It is
good There is in this case It is
difficult to  analyze
a
Meis Now May future there will be some
neurological Research that be able to
explain the mouse brain and mouse retina
Right but It is typical of Human Beings
to use
Instinct
forys
particular with this ability to
instantly diagnose this is typical of
Human Being you cannot  implement in i
collaborated with the The computational
Scientist to programs
of the First decade of artificial
intelligence on diagnostic Medical
reasoning and in That case You have to
program and so then you can say the
result of the Machine
typ a of philosophical and psychological
ter and so  i avoided it Just because it was
not Opportunity
to Abduction in
Ann
our syntic language They are capable to
arve very Question weak for Car
over Than You letak and Come back and
Disc
[Applause]
[Music]
than